The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Now
today, we're going
to talk about random walks.
And in particular, we're going
to look at a classic phenomenon
known as Gamblers Ruin.
It's a great way
to end the term,
because the solution requires
several of the techniques
that we've developed
since the midterm.
So it's actually a good review.
We'll review recurrences.
We'll review a lot
of probability laws.
And it's actually a
nice problem to look at.
It's another example where you
get a non-intuitive solution
using probability.
And if you like to
gamble, it's really good
that you look at this problem
before you go to Vegas or down
to Foxwoods.
Now the Gambler's Ruin problem,
you start with n dollars.
And we're going to do a
simplified version, where
in each bet, you win
$1 or you lose $1.
Now, these days, there are not
many bets in a casino for $1.
It's more like $10.
But just to make it
simple for counting,
we're going to
assume that each bet
you win $1 with
probability p, and you lose
$1 with probability 1 minus p.
And in this version,
we're going to assume
you keep playing until
one of two things
happens-- you get
ahead by m dollars,
or you lose all the money you
came with-- all n dollars.
So you play until you
win m more-- net m plus--
or you lose n.
And that's where you go broke.
You run out of money.
And we're going to assume
you don't borrow anything
from the house.
All right, and we're going
to look at the probability
that you come out a winner
versus going home broke--
that you made m dollars.
Now, the game we're going
to analyze is roulette,
but the technique
works for any of them.
How many people
have played roulette
before in some form or another?
OK, so this is a
game where there's
the ball that goes around the
dish, and you spin the wheel.
And there's 36
numbers from 1 to 36.
Half of them are
red, half are black.
And then there's the zero and
the double zero that are green.
And we're going to
look at the version
where you just bet
on red or black.
And you win if the ball
lands on a slot that's red.
And there's 18 of those.
And you lose otherwise.
So in this case, the
probability of winning, p,
is there's 18 chances to win.
And it's not 36 total.
It's 38 total because of the
zero and the double zero.
All right so this is
9/19 chance of winning
and a 10/19 chance of losing.
And so this is a game that has a
chance of winning of about 47%,
so it's almost a fair game.
It's not 50-50.
And that's because the casino's
got to make some money.
I mean, they have
the big facility.
They're giving you free
drinks, and all the rest.
So they got to
make money somehow.
And they make money on
this bet because they're
going to make $0.03
on the dollar here.
You're going to wager.
And then you're going
to come back with 47%.
And people generally
are fine with that.
They don't expect to have
the odds in their favor
when you're gambling
in a casino.
Now, in an effort to sort
of come home a winner,
the way people do that--
knowing that the odds are
a little against
them-- is they might
put more money in
their pocket coming in
than they expect to win.
So often, you'll see
people come into the casino
with the goal of winning 100,
but they start with 1,000
in their pocket.
So they're willing
to risk $1,000,
but they're going to quit
happy if they get up 100.
OK so you either go
home with $1,100,
or you're going home
with $0, in this case.
And you came with $1,000.
And this means that you're--
at least the thinking goes--
this means you're more
likely to go home happy.
If you quit when
you get up by 100,
you're more likely
to land there,
because it's almost a fair game,
than you are to lose all 1,000.
That's the thinking anyway.
In fact, my mother-in-law
plays roulette, red and black,
and she follows the strategy.
And she claims that she
does this for that reason--
that she almost always wins.
She goes home happy
almost always.
And that's the
important thing here.
And it does reasonable,
because after all, roulette
is almost a fair game.
So what do you think?
How many people
think she's right
that she almost always wins?
Anybody?
I have sort of set it up.
It's my mother-in-law,
after all,
so probably she's
going to be wrong.
Well, how many people think
it's better than a 50% chance
you win $100 before
you lose $1,000?
That's probably
more-- how many people
think you're more likely to
lose $1,000 before you win $100?
Wow, OK, so you've been
to 6.04 too long now.
OK, what about this-- how
many people think you're
more likely to lose
$10,000 than to win $100?
All right, how many
people think you're
more likely to lose $1 million?
A bunch of you still think that.
OK, well, you're right.
In fact, it is almost
certain you will go broke,
no matter how much money you
bring, before you win $100.
In fact, we're
going to prove today
that the probability that
you win $100 before losing
$100 million if you
stayed long enough-- that
takes a while-- the chance you
go home a winner is less than 1
in 37,648.
You have no chance
to go home happy.
So my mother-in-law's telling me
the story about how she always
goes home happy.
And I'm saying, no, no,
wait a minute, you can't.
You never went home happy.
Let's be honest.
It can't be.
She goes, no, no, no, it's true.
I go, no, look, there's
a mathematical proof.
I have a proof.
I can show you my proof-- very
unlikely you go home a winner.
So somehow, she's
not very impressed
with the mathematical proof.
And she keeps insisting.
And I keep trying to
show her the proof.
And anyway, I hope I'll have
more luck with you guys today
in showing you the proof that
the chance you go home happy
here is very, very small.
Now, in the end, I
didn't convince her,
but we'll see how
we do here today.
Now, in order to see why this
probability is so stunningly
small-- you would just
never guess it's that low--
we've got to learn
about random walks.
And they come up in all
sorts of applications.
In fact, page rank--
that got Google started--
it's all based on a random
walk through the Web
or through the links on
web pages on that graph.
Now, for the gambling
problem, we're
going to look at a
very special case--
probably the simplest
case of a random walk--
and that's a
one-dimensional random walk.
In a one-dimensional
random walk,
there's some value-- say
the number of dollars
you've got in your pocket.
And this value can
go up, or go down,
or stay the same each time you
do something like make a bet.
And each of this happens
with a certain probability.
Now in this case, you
either go up by one,
or you go down by one, and
you can't stay the same.
Every bet you win
$1 or you lose $1.
So it's really a special case.
And we can diagram
it as follows.
We can put time, or the
number of bets, on this axis.
And we can put the number
of dollars on this axis.
Now in this case, we
start with n dollars.
And we might win the first
bet, so we go to n plus 1.
We might lose a bet, might lose
again, could win the next one,
lose, win, lose, lose.
So this corresponds to a
string-- win, lose, lose, lose,
lose, win, lose, win,
lose, lose, lose.
And when we win, we go up $1.
When we lose, we go down $1.
And it's called
one-dimensional, because there's
just one thing that's changing.
You're going up and down there.
Now, the probability
of going up is p.
And that's no matter
what happened before.
It's a memoryless
independent system.
The probability you win your
i-th bet has nothing to do--
is totally independent,
mutually independent-- of all
the other bets that
took place before.
So let's write that down.
So the probability
of an up move is p.
The probability of a
down move is 1 minus p.
And these are mutually
independent of past moves.
Now, when you have
a random walk where
the moves are
mutually independent,
it has a special name.
It's called a martingale.
All random walks
don't have to have
mutually independent steps.
Say you're looking
about winning and losing
a baseball game in a series.
We looked at a scenario
where, if you lost yesterday,
you're feeling lousy,
more likely to lose today.
Not true in the
gambling case here.
It's mutually independent.
And that's the only
case we're going
to study for random walks.
Now, if p is not 1/2, the random
walk is said to be biased.
And that's what
happens in the casino.
It's biased in
favor of the house.
If p equals 1/2, then the
random walk is unbiased.
Now, in this particular
case that we're looking at,
we have boundaries
on the random walk.
There's a boundary
at 0, because you
go home broke if
you lost everything.
If the random walk ever
hit $0, you're done.
And we're also going to
put a boundary at n plus m.
So I'm going to have
a boundary here.
So that if I win m dollars here,
I stop and I go home happy.
If the random walk ever
goes here, then I stop.
Those are called boundary
conditions for the walk.
And what we want to do is
analyze the probability
that we hit that top
boundary before we
hit the bottom boundary.
So we're going to define
that event to be W star.
W star is the event that the
random walk hits T, which
is n plus m, before it hits 0.
In other words, you go home
happy without going broke.
Let's also define D to be the
number of dollars at the start.
And this is just going
to be n in our case.
We're interested in, call it
X sub n is the probability
that we go home happy given
we started with n dollars.
And that's a function of n.
So we'll make a
variable called X n.
And we want to know what
that probability is.
And of course, the
more you come with,
you'd think it's a
higher chance of winning
the more you have
in your pocket,
because you can play for more.
So the goal is to
figure this out.
Now to do this, we could
use the tree method.
But it gets pretty complicated,
because the sample space
is the sample space of
all one-loss sequences.
And how big is
that sample space?
AUDIENCE: Infinite.
PROFESSOR: Infinite.
I could play forever.
All right, now it turns out the
probability of playing forever
is 0.
And we won't prove that, but
there are an infinite number
of sample points.
So doing the tree method
is a little complicated
when it's infinite.
So what we're going
to do is use some
of the theorems we've proved
over the last few weeks
and set up a recurrence
to find this probability.
Now, I'm going to tell you
what the recurrence is,
and then prove
that that's right.
So I claim that X
n is 0 probability
if we start with $0.
It's 1 if we start
with T dollars.
And it's p times X n minus
1 plus 1 minus p X n plus 1
if we start with between
$0 and T dollars.
All right, so that's
what I claim X n is.
And it's, of course, a
recursion that I've set up here.
So let's see why
that's the case.
OK, so let's check the 0 case.
X 0 is the probability
we go home a winner given
we started with $0.
Why is that 0?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you started broke.
You never get off the
ground, because you
quit as soon as you have $0.
So you have no chance to win,
because you're broke to start.
Let's check the next case,
X T-- case n equals T--
is the probability you
go home a winner given
you started with T dollars.
Why is that 1?
Why is that certain, sort
of from the definition?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You already
have your money.
You already hit
the top boundary,
because you started there.
Remember, you quit
and you're happy.
Go home happy if
you hit T dollars.
All right, so you're
guaranteed to go home happy,
because you never make any bets.
You started with all the money
you needed to go home happy.
Then we have the
interesting case,
where you start with
between 0 and T dollars.
And now you're going
to make some bets.
And then X n is the
probability-- just
the definition-- of going
home happy-- i.e. winning
and having T dollars,
if you start with n.
Now, there's two cases to
analyze this, based on what
happens in the first bet.
You could win it, or
you could lose it.
And then we're going to recurse.
So we're going to define
E to be the event that you
win the first bet.
And E bar is the event that
you lose the first bet.
Now, by the theory of
total probability, which
we did in recitation
maybe a couple weeks ago,
we can rewrite this depending
on whether E happened
or the complement of E happened.
And you get that the
probability is simply
the probability of
going home happy
and winning the
first bet times--
and I've got to put
the conditioning in.
That doesn't go away.
So I'm breaking into two cases.
The first one is you win the
first bet given D equals n,
And the case where you lose the
first bet, given D equals n.
Any questions here?
The probability of
going home happy
given you start with n
dollars is the probability
of going home happy and winning
the first bet given D equals
n plus the probability
of going home happy
and losing the first
bet given D equals n--
just those are the two cases.
Now I can use the definition
of conditional probability
to rewrite these.
This is the probability--
you've got two events--
that the first one
happens given D equals n
times the probability
the second one happens
given that the first one
happened and D equals n.
This is just the definition
of conditional probability,
when I've got an
intersection of events here.
The probability
of both happening
is the probability of
the first happening
times the probability of
the second happening given
that the first happened.
And of course, everything is
in this universe of D equals n.
So I've used it in a
little different twist
than we had it before.
The same thing over
here-- this now
is the probability of E
prime given D equals n
times the probability of
W star-- winning, going
home happy-- given that you lost
the first bet and D equals n.
That's D equals n there.
So it looks like it's
got more complicated,
but now we can
start simplifying.
What's the
probability of winning
the first bet given that
you started with n dollars?
AUDIENCE: p.
PROFESSOR: p-- in
fact, does this
have anything to do with
the probability of winning
the first bet?
No, this is just p.
Now, what about this thing?
I am conditioning on
winning the first bet given
and I start with n dollars.
What's another way of
expressing I won the first bet
and I started with n dollars?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You have n plus $1.
PROFESSOR: I now have n
plus $1 going forward.
And because I have a
martingale, and everything
is mutually independent,
it's like the world
starts all over again.
I'm now in a state
with n plus $1,
and I want to know
the probability
that I go home happy.
It doesn't matter how
I got the n plus $1.
It's just going forward-- I
got n plus $1 in my pocket,
I want to know the probability
of going home happy.
So I reset to D equals n plus 1.
So I replace this with that,
because however long it
took me to get there and
all that stuff doesn't
matter for this analysis.
It's all mutually dependent.
Probability of losing the
first bet given that I started
with n dollars-- 1 minus p.
Doesn't matter how
much I started with.
And here, I want to know the
probability of going home happy
given-- well, if I
lost the first bet
and I started with
n, what have I got?
n minus 1.
It doesn't matter how
I got to n minus 1.
Now this is going to
get really simple.
What's another name
for that expression?
X n plus 1.
And another name
for this expression?
X n minus 1.
So we proved that X n equals
p X n plus 1 plus 1 minus
p X n minus 1.
And that's what I
claimed is true.
So we finished the proof.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Did i screw it up?
PROFESSOR: I claim probability
of winning-- so let's
see if I have a wrong in here.
I might have screwed it up.
I think I proved
it's n plus 1, right?
Yep, sure enough, I
think this is a plus 1.
That's a minus 1.
Now, it's always good to
check to you proved what you
said you were going to prove.
So I needed to change this.
That's what I proved.
Any other questions?
That was a pretty
important question.
All right, so we have
a recurrence for X n.
Now, it's a little
funny looking at first,
because normally
with a recurrence,
X n would depend on X
sub i that are smaller--
the i's are smaller than n.
So it looks a little wacky.
But is that a problem?
I can just solve
for X n plus 1--
just subtract this
and put it over there.
So let's do that.
OK, so if I solve for X n plus 1
up there, I'll put p X n plus 1
on its own side, I get p X
n plus 1 minus X n plus 1
minus p X n minus 1 equals 0.
And I know that X 0 is 0.
And I know that X T equals 1.
Now, what type of
recurrence is this?
AUDIENCE: Linear.
PROFESSOR: Linear, good, so
it's a linear recurrence.
And what type of linear
recurrence is it?
AUDIENCE: Homogeneous.
PROFESSOR: Homogeneous-- that's
the best case, simple case,
that's good.
The boundary conditions
are a little weird,
because the recurrences
we all saw before,
if we had two
boundary conditions it
would be X0 and X1.
Here it's X0 and X T.
But all's you need are two.
Doesn't matter where they are.
So how do I solve that thing?
What's the next thing I do?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Characterize
the equation.
PROFESSOR: Characterize
And what do you do
it that equation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Solve
it, get the roots.
This'll be good
practice for the final,
because you'll probably have
to do something like this.
So that's the
characteristic equation.
And what's the order of
this equation-- the degree?
That's going to be 2, right?
I'm going to have pr squared
minus r plus 1 minus p is 0.
That's my
characteristic equation.
Remember that?
So I make this be
the constant term.
Then I have the
first-order term, then
the second-order term.
All right, now I solve it.
And that's easy for a
second-order equation.
1 plus or minus the square
root of 1 minus 4p 1
minus p over 2 p.
Let's do that.
OK, so this is 1 plus
or minus the square root
of 1 minus 4p plus
4p squared over 2p.
Just using the quadratic
formula and simplifying.
And it works out really
nicely, because that
is the square root of-- this
is just 1 minus 2p squared.
So that's 1 plus or
minus 1 minus 2p over 2p.
And that is 2 minus 2p over
2p or 1 minus 1 cancels,
then minus 2p is 2p over 2p.
So the answers, the roots
are divide by 2 on this one.
I get 1 minus p over p and 1.
Those are the roots.
Are these roots different?
Do I have the case
of a double root?
Are the roots always different?
They're usually different.
What's the case where
these roots are the same?
AUDIENCE: 0.5.
PROFESSOR: 0.5, which is
sort of an interesting case
in this game.
Because if p equals 1/2, we
have an unbiased random walk.
You got a fair game.
And so it says right away,
well, maybe the result
is going to be different for
a fair game than the game
we're playing in the
casino, where it's biased.
So let's look at the casino
game where p is not 1/2.
Then the roots are different.
Later, we'll go back
and analyze the case
when the roots of the
same for the fair game.
So if p is not 1/2, then
we can solve for X n.
X n is some constant times the
first root to the nth power
plus a constant times the
second root to the nth power.
Remember, that's how it works
for any linear homogeneous
recurrence.
And that's easy, because
the second root was 1.
This is just plus
B. 1 to the n is 1.
How do I figure out
what A and B are?
AUDIENCE: Boundary conditions.
PROFESSOR: Boundary
conditions, very good.
So let's look at the
boundary conditions.
OK, so the first boundary
condition is at 0.
So we have 0 equals X 0.
Plugging in there-- oops
I forgot the n up here.
Plugging in n equals 0--
well, this to the 0 is just 1.
That is A plus B. That
means that B equals minus A.
Then the second
boundary condition
is 1 equals X sub T.
And that is A 1 minus
p over p to the T plus
B, but B was minus A.
And now I can solve for A.
So that means that A equals
1 over 1 minus p over p
to the T minus 1.
And B is negative A--
minus 1 over 1 minus p,
over p to the T minus 1.
And then I plug those back
in to the formula for X n.
So here's my constant A.
I multiply that times 1
minus p over p to the
n, plus I add this in.
So this means that the
probability of going home
a winner is 1 minus p over p to
the n over that thing-- 1 minus
p over p to the T
minus 1, plus the B
term, which really is a minus
term here, is just minus 1.
Put that on top here.
That sort of looks
messy, but there's
a simplification to get an
upper bound that's very close.
In particular, if you have
a biased game against you--
so if p is less than 1/2,
as it is in roulette,
then this is a
number bigger than 1.
That means that 1 minus p
over p is bigger than 1.
So this is bigger than 1.
This is bigger than 1.
T is the upper limit.
It's n plus m.
So I've got a bigger number
down here than I do here.
So overall, it's a
fraction less than 1.
And when you have a
fraction less than 1,
if you add 1 to the
numerator and denominator,
it gets closer to 1.
It gets bigger.
So this is upper-bounded by
just adding 1 to each of these.
Its upper-bounded by this
over that, which is 1 minus p
over p to the n minus T.
And T is just n plus m.
So this equals-- why don't
I turn it upside down?
Make it p over 1 minus p to get
a fraction that's less than 1.
T minus n, and that equals
p over 1 minus p to the m.
And this is how much you're
trying to get ahead-- $100
in the case of my mother-in-law.
So what we've
proved-- let me state
what we proved as a theorem.
So we proved that if
p is less than 1/2--
if you're more
likely to lose a bet
than win it-- then
the probability
that you win m dollars before
you lose n dollars is at most p
over 1 minus p to the m.
That's what we just proved.
And so now you can plug
in values-- for example,
for roulette.
p equals 9/19, which
means that p over 1
minus p-- that's going
to be 9/19 over 10/19,
which is just 9/10.
And if m-- the amount you
want to win-- is $100,
and n is $1,000-- that's
what you start with
and you're willing
to lose-- well,
the probability you win--
you go home happy-- W
star you win $100-- is
less than or equal to 9/10
raised to the m, which is 100.
So it's 9/10 of 100, and that
turns out to be less than 1
in 37,648, which is where
that answer came from.
Now you can see why
my mother-in-law
may have got lost somewhere
here now in the calculations.
But this is a proof
that the chance
you win $100 before you lose
$1,000 is very, very small.
Now, do you see why the answer
is no better than if you came
with $1 million in your pocket?
Say you came with n
equals $1 million.
Why is the answer not changing?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Once you
lose, say, $1,000,
you're already in
a really deep hole.
PROFESSOR: That's the intuition.
That's right.
We're going to get
to that in a minute.
I want to know from
the formula, why
is it no difference if I come
with $1,000 versus $1 million?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The formula
doesn't have n.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the formula
has nothing to do with n.
You could come with $100
trillion in your wallet,
and it doesn't
improve this bound.
This bound only depends on
what you're trying to win,
not on how much you came with.
So no matter how
much you come with,
the chance you win $100
before you lose everything
is at most 1 in 37,000.
Now, we can plug in
some other values
just for fun--
different values of m.
If you thought 1 in
37,000 was unlikely,
the chance of winning
$1,000, or 1,000 bets worth
before you're broke-- that's
less than 9/10 to the 1,000.
That's less than 2 times
10 to the minus 46--
really, really, really unlikely.
Even winning $10 is not likely.
Just plug in the numbers.
The probability you win
$10 betting $1 at a time
is less than 9/10
to the 10th power.
That's less than 0.35.
You can come to the casino with
$10 million, bet $1 at a time,
and you quit if you just
get up 10 bets-- get up $10.
The chance you get up $10 before
you lose $10 million is about 1
in 3 you're twice as
likely to lose $10 million
as you are to win 10.
That just seems weird, right?
Because it's almost a fair game.
It's almost 50-50.
Any questions
about the analysis?
Yes, I find that shocking.
Just the intuition would
seem say otherwise.
So I guess there's a moral here.
If you're going to
gamble, learn how
to count cards in blackjack,
or some game where
you can make it even.
Because even in a game
where it's pretty close,
you're doomed.
You're just never
going to go home happy.
Now, if you could
have a fair game,
the world changes-- much
better circumstance.
So actually, let's do the
same analysis for a fair game,
because that's where our
intuition really comes from.
Because we're thinking of
this game as almost fair.
And in a fair game, the answer's
going to be very different.
And it all goes back to the
recurrence and the roots
of the characteristic equation.
Because in a fair
game, p is 1/2.
And then you have a double root.
1 minus 1/2 over 1/2 equals 1,
and that means a double root
at 1.
And that changes everything.
So let's go through now
and do all this analysis
in the case of a fair game.
And this will give us
practice with double roots
and recurrences.
Because as you see
now, it does happen.
Let's figure out the chance
that we go home a winner.
OK, so let's see.
In this case, we know the roots.
Can anybody tell me
what formula we're
going to use for the solution?
Got a double root at 1.
So there's going to
be a 1 to the n here.
I don't just put a
constant A in front.
What do I do with a double root?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: A n.
PROFESSOR: What is it?
PROFESSOR: A n-- not quite A n.
You got an A n here.
AUDIENCE: Plus B.
PROFESSOR: Plus B-- that's
what you do for a double root,
because you make a first
degree polynomial in n here.
So we plug that in.
The root's at 1,
so it's real easy.
The solution's really easy now.
No messy powers or anything.
It's just A n plus B. And
I can figure out A and B
from the boundary conditions.
All right, X0 is 0.
X 0 is just B, because
it's A times 0 goes away.
And that means that B equals 0.
This is getting really simple.
1 is X T. And that's
A plus B, but B was 0.
So that's A times 1
plus B. That's just A.
It means A equals A n.
Good, n's not 1.
N's T. So it's A T plus B.
This is A T here.
So A T equals 1.
That means A is 1 over T.
All right, that means that
X n is n over T. And T
is the total.
The top limit is n plus
m, because you quit
if you get ahead m dollars.
This is just now
n over n plus m.
All right, so let's
write that down.
It's a theorem.
If p is 1/2, i.e., you
have a fair game, then
the probability
you win m dollars
before you lose n dollars
is just n over n plus m.
And this might fit
the intuition better.
So for the mother-in-law
strategy, if m is 100,
and n is 1,000, what's
the probability you
win-- you go home a winner?
Yeah, 1,000 over 1,000 plus 100.
1,000 over 1,000 is 10 over 11.
So she does go home happy most
of the time-- 10 out of 11
nights-- if she's
playing a fair game.
Any questions about that?
So the trouble we get into
here is that the fair game
results match our intuition.
You know if you have 10 times
as much money in a fair game,
you'd expect to go home
happy 10 out of 11 nights.
That makes a lot of sense.
You go home happy 10, and
then you lose the 11th.
That's a 10 to 1 ratio,
which is the money
you brought into the game.
The trouble we get
into is, the fair game
is very close to the real game.
Instead of 50-50, it's 47-53.
And so our intuition
says the results--
the probability of going
home happy in a fair game--
should be close to the
probability of going
home happy in the real game.
And that's not true.
There's a discontinuity here
because of the double root.
And the character
completely changes.
So instead of being
close to 10 out of 11,
you're down there
at 1 in 37,000--
completely different behavior.
OK, any questions?
All right, so let me
give you an-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what
happens if you make n 1,
and then you do that repeatedly?
PROFESSOR: Now, if
I did n equals 1,
I could use that
as an upper bound,
and it's not so
interesting as, say, 90%.
But I would actually go
plug it back in here.
So this would be n plus
1, and it would depend
how much money I brought.
But there is a pretty good
chance I go home a winner for m
equals 1.
Because I've got a pretty
good chance that I either--
47% chance I win the first time.
Then I go home happy.
If I lost the first time, now
I've just got to win twice.
And I might win twice in a row.
That'll happen about
20% of the time.
If I lose that, now I've
got to win three in a row.
That'll happen around
10% of the time.
So I've got 10 plus
20 plus almost 50.
Most of the time, I'm going
to go home happy if I just
have to get ahead by $1.
But it doesn't take
much more than one
before you're not
likely to go home happy.
Getting ahead 10 is not
going to happen, very likely.
Now, you want to
recurse on that?
I'm pretty likely
to get ahead by one.
Well, OK, get ahead by one.
I'm pretty likely
to do it again.
And I did it again.
Now I'm pretty likely
to do it again.
And there's this
thing called induction
that we worried a lot about.
So by induction, are we likely
to go home happy with 10?
No, because every time you
don't get there, you're dead.
You had a little chance of
dying and not reaching one,
and a little chance of dying
and not going from one to two.
And you add up all
those chances of dying,
and you're toast, because
that'll be adding up
to everything, pretty much.
So that's a good question.
If you're likely
to get up by one,
why aren't you likely
to get up by 10?
It doesn't work that way.
That's a great question.
Let me show you the phenomenon
that's going on here, as
to why it works out this way.
We had the math.
So we looked at it that way.
We notice that one case is a
double root and the other case
isn't.
And that exponential,
in the case
where you didn't have
that second root at 1
makes an enormous difference.
Qualitatively, we can
draw the two cases.
So in the case of an
unbiased or fair game,
if we track what's
going on over time,
and we start with n dollars,
sort of this is our baseline.
And here's our
target-- T is n plus m.
And so we quit if
we ever get here.
And we quit if we
ever hit the bottom.
And we've got a random walk.
It's going around, just
doing this kind of stuff.
And eventually, it's going to
hit one of these boundaries.
And if m is small
compared to n, we're
more likely to
hit this boundary.
And in fact, the chance
we hit this boundary first
is the ratio of these sizes.
It's n over the total.
It's the chance that
we hit that one first.
Now in the biased case, the
picture looks different.
So in the biased case--
so this is now biased.
And we're going to assume
it's downward biased.
You're more likely to lose.
So you start at n, you've
got your boundary up here
at T equals n plus m.
Time is going this way.
The problem is, you've got
a downward sort of baseline,
because you expect to lose
a little bit each time.
And so you're taking
this random walk.
And you collide here.
And these things are
known as the swings.
This is known as the drift.
And the drift downward
is 1 minus 2p.
That's what you expect to
lose if you get the expected
loss on each bet-- 1 minus 2p.
Because you're going
to not be a fair game.
This one has zero
drift up there.
It stays steady.
And in random walks, drift
outweighs the swings.
These are the swings here.
And they're random.
The drift is deterministic.
It's steadily going down.
And so almost always
in a random walk,
the drift totally
takes over the swings.
The swings are small
compared to what you're
losing on a steady basis.
And that's why you're so
much more likely to lose when
you have the drift downward.
Just as an example, maybe
putting some numbers
around that.
The swings are the
same in both cases,
So that gives you some
qualification for how big
the swings tend to be.
We can sort of do that with
standard deviation notation.
After X bets or X steps,
the amount you've drifted,
or the expected
losses, 1 minus 2p
X. Maybe we should
just understand
why this is the case.
The expected return on a
bet is 1 with probability p,
and minus 1 with
probability 1 minus p.
And so that is-- did
I get that right?
I think that's right.
Oh, expected loss--
[INAUDIBLE] drifts down.
Instead of expected
return, let's do the loss,
because that's the drift.
It's a downward thing.
So the expected loss-- now
you lose $1 with 1 minus p.
And you gain $1, which
is negative loss,
with probability p.
And so you get 1 minus
p minus p is 1 minus 2p.
So that's your expected loss.
Your expected winnings
are the negative of that.
So after x steps, you
expect to lose-- well,
I just add up the
linearity of expectation.
You expect to lose
this much x times.
So that's your expected drift.
You're expected
to lose that much.
Now, the swing--
and we won't prove
this-- the swing is expected
to be square root of x
times a constant.
So I've used the
theta notation here.
And the constant is small.
If I take x consecutive
bets for $1,
I'm very likely to be
about square root of x
off of the expected drift.
And you can see that
this is square root.
That is linear.
So this totally dominates that.
So the swings are generally
not enough to save you.
And so you're just going to
cruise downward and crash,
almost surely.
OK, any questions about that?
All right, so we figured out
the probability of winning m
dollars before going broke.
That's done with.
Now, this means it's
logical to conclude
you're likely go home
broke in an unfair game.
Actually, before we do
that, there's one other case
we've got to rule out.
We've proved you're likely
not to go home a winner.
Does that necessarily mean
you're likely to go broke?
I've been saying that, but
there's some other thing
we should check.
What's one way you
might not go home broke?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What is it?
AUDIENCE: You don't go home.
PROFESSOR: You don't go home.
And why would you not go home?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You're
playing forever.
PROFESSOR: You're
playing forever-- we
didn't rule out that case--
you're playing forever.
But it turns out, if you
did the same analysis,
you can analyze the probability
of going home broke.
And when you add it to the
probability of going home
a winner, it adds to 1,
which means the probability
playing forever is 0.
Now, there are sample points
where you play forever.
But when you add up all
those sample points,
if their probability
is 0, we ignore them.
And we say it can't happen.
Now, we're bordering
on philosophy here,
because there is a
sample point here.
You could win, lose, win,
lose, win, lose forever.
But because you add them
all up at 0, measure theory
and some math we're not
going to get into tells you
it doesn't happen.
It's probability 1 you're
a winner or a loser.
All right, so I'm
not going to prove
that the probability
you play forever is 0.
But let's look at
how long you play.
How long does it take you to
go home one way or another-- go
broke?
And to do this, we're going
to set up another recurrence.
So we know eventually
we hit a boundary.
I want to know how
many bets does it
take to hit the boundary?
How long do we get to play
before we go home unhappy?
So S will be the number of
steps until we hit a boundary.
And I want to know the
expected number-- I'll call it
E sub n here-- is the
expected value of S given
that I start with n dollars.
I mean, the reason
you could think
about this is, we know
we're going to go home
broke-- pretty likely.
Do we at least have some
fun in the meantime?
Do we get a lot gambling in
and free drinks, or whatever,
before we're killed here?
Now, this also has a recurrence.
And I'm going to show
you what it is, then
prove that that's correct.
So I claim that
the expected number
of steps given we
start with n dollars
is 0 if we start with no money,
because we are already broke.
It's 0 if we start
with T dollars,
because then we
just go home happy.
There's no bets, because we've
already hit the upper boundary.
And the interesting case will be
it's 1 plus p times E n minus 1
plus 1 minus p-- oops, n plus
1-- 1 minus p E n minus 1,
if we start with
between 0 and T dollars.
OK, so let's prove that.
Actually, the proof is exactly
the same as the last one.
So I don't think
I need to do it.
The proof is pretty simple,
because we look at two cases.
You win the first bet--
happens with probability p.
And then you're starting
with n plus $1 over again.
Or you lose the
first bet-- happens
with probability 1 minus p.
And you're starting
over with n minus $1
now-- same as last time.
In fact, this
whole recurrence is
identical to last time
except for one thing.
What's the one thing
that's different now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What is it?
AUDIENCE: You have [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You have--
AUDIENCE: So it's not
[INAUDIBLE] any more.
PROFESSOR: That's different.
There's another difference.
That's one difference that's
going to make it inhomogeneous.
That's sort of a pain.
What's the other
difference from last time?
This part's the same otherwise.
AUDIENCE: Boundaries.
PROFESSOR: What is it?
AUDIENCE: Boundary conditions.
PROFESSOR: Boundary conditions--
that was a 1 before.
Now it's a 0.
OK, so a little change
here, and I added a 1 here.
But that's going to make it
a pretty different answer.
So let's see what
the recurrence is.
I'll rearrange terms here
to put it into recurrence.
I get p E sub n plus 1 minus
E n plus 1 minus p E n minus 1
equals minus 1, not 0.
And the boundary conditions
are E 0 is 0 and E T is 0.
OK, what's the
first thing you do
when you have an inhomogeneous
linear recurrence?
Solve the homogeneous one.
And the answer there-- well,
it's the same as before.
This is the part we analyzed.
And we'll do it for
the case when p is not
1/2-- so the unfair game.
So the homogeneous
solution is E n
just from before-- same
thing-- 1 minus p over p
to the n plus B. And this
is the case with two roots.
p does not equal 1/2.
What's the next thing you do
for inhomogeneous recurrence?
Are we plugging in
boundary conditions yet?
No.
So what do I do next?
Particular solution.
And what's my first guess?
We have the recurrence
like this here.
What do I guess for E n?
I'm trying to guess something
that looks like that.
So what do I guess?
Constant, yeah.
That's a scalar.
I just guess a constant.
And if I plug a constant a
into here, it's going to fail.
Because I'll just
pull the a out.
I'll get p minus 1
plus 1 minus p is 0,
and 0 doesn't equal minus 1.
So it fails.
So I guess again.
What do I guess next time?
a n plus b.
All right, and I
don't think I'll
drag you through all the
algebra for that, but it works.
And when you do it, you
find that a is minus 1
over 2p minus 1.
And b could be anything.
So let me just rewrite
this as 1 over 1 minus 2p.
And b can be anything, so
we'll set b equal to 0.
So we've got our
particular solution.
It's not hard to
go compute that.
You just plug it
back in and solve.
Now we add them together to
get the general solution.
This is A n plus B. B was 0, and
here's A as 1 over 1 minus 2p.
And now what do we do to finish?
I've got my general
solution here
by adding up the homogeneous
and the particular solution.
Plug in the boundary conditions.
All right, I'm not going to drag
you through solving this case,
but I'm going to
show you the answer.
E n equals n over 1 minus 2p
minus T, the upper boundary,
over 1 minus 2p times 1 minus p
over p to the n minus 1 over 1
minus p over p to the T minus 1.
So actually, this looks a little
familiar from the last time
when we did this recurrence,
figuring out the probability we
go home a winner.
Here this is the
expected number of steps
to hit a boundary, to go home.
If we plug in the values,
it's a little hairy,
but you can compute it.
So for example, if m
is 100, n is 1,000,
T would be 1,100 in that case.
p is 9/19 playing roulette.
Then the expected number of
bets before you have to go home
is 1,900 from this part,
minus 0.56 from that part.
So actually 19,000, sorry.
So it's very close to 19,000
bets you've got to make.
So it takes a long
time to lose $1,000.
And it sort of comes
very close to the answer
you would have guessed
without thinking and solving
the recurrence.
If you expect to lose
1 minus 2p every bet,
and you want to know how long
the expected time to lose
n dollars, you might
well have said,
I think it's going to be n over
the amount I lose every time.
That would be
wrong, technically,
because you'd have left
off this nasty thing.
But this nasty thing doesn't
make much of a real difference,
because it goes to 0 really
fast for any numbers like 100
and 1,000-- makes no
difference at all.
So the intuition in
that case comes out
to be pretty close, even
though technically, it's
not exactly right.
Now, to see why this goes to
0, if T equals n plus m here--
this is n plus m--
and your upper limits,
say m goes to infinity--
it's 100 in this case-- then
that just zooms to 0, and
you're only left with that.
Which means that we can use
asymptotic notation here
to sort of characterize the
expected number of bets.
And it's totally
dominated by the drift.
So as m goes to infinity, the
expected time to live here
is tilde n over 1 minus 2p.
If you've got n dollars,
losing 1 minus 2p every time,
then you last for n
over 1 minus 2p steps.
OK, now, actually,
what situation in words
does m going to infinity mean?
Say I set m to be infinity?
What is that kind of
game if m is infinity?
How long am I playing now?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Now you're
playing for as long as
it takes you to lose
all of your money.
PROFESSOR: Yes, because there is
no stopping condition up here--
going home happy.
I'm going to play forever
or until I lose everything.
And this says how long
you expect to play.
It's a little less
than n over 1 minus 2p.
So if you play
until you go broke,
that's how long
you expect to play.
So that sort of makes
sense in that scenario.
That's not one where it
surprises you by intuition.
It is interesting to consider
the case of a fair game.
Because there's something
that's non-intuitive
that happens there.
So in a fair game, p is 1/2.
Now, if I plug in 1/2
here, well, I divide by 0.
I expect to play forever.
That's not a good way
to do the analysis,
that you get to a divide by 0.
Let's actually go
back and look at this
for the case when p is 1/2.
And see what happens
in a fair game--
how long you expect to
play in a fair game.
Then the homogeneous
solution is the simple case.
E is A n plus B. You
have a double root at 1,
which we don't have to
worry about 1 to the n.
When you do your
particular solution,
you'll try a single
scalar, and it fails.
I'll use lowercase a-- fails.
You will then try a degree one
polynomial, and that will fail.
What are you going to try next?
Second-degree polynomial,
and that will work.
OK, and the answer
you get when you
do that is that-- I'll
put the answer here.
It turns out that a is minus
1 and b and c can be 0.
So it's just going
to be minus n squared
for the particular solution.
That means your general solution
is A n plus B minus n squared.
Now you do your
boundary condition.
You have E 0 is 0.
Plug in 0 for n.
That's equal to B. So B is 0.
That's nice.
E T is 0.
And I plug in T here, I get
AT, B is 0 minus T squared.
So I solve for A here.
That means that A equals T. AT
squared minus T squared is 0.
A has to be T.
So that means that E n
is Tn minus n squared.
Now, T is the upper bound.
It's just n plus m.
n plus m times n
minus n squared--
this gets really simple.
The m squared cancels.
I just get n out.
That says if you're playing
a fair game, until you
win m or lose n, you expect
to play for nm steps, which
is really nice.
This is p is 1/2-- very clean.
Now, if you let m
equal to infinity,
you're going to expect
to play forever.
So with a fair game, if you
play until you're broke,
the expected number
of bets is infinite.
That's nice.
You can play forever
is the expectation.
Now, here's the weird thing.
If you expect to play
forever, does that
mean you're not likely
to go home broke?
You expect to play forever.
And as long as you're playing,
you're not going home broke.
Now, there's some chance
of going home broke,
because you might just lose
every bet-- not likely.
Here's the weird
thing-- the probability
you go home broke if you
play until you go broke is 1.
You will go home broke.
It's just that it
takes you expected
infinite amount
of time to do it--
sort of one of these weird
things in a fair game.
So here we proved the
expected number bets is nm.
If m is infinite, that becomes
an infinite number of bets.
One more theorem here-- this
one's a little surprising.
This theorem is called
Quit While You're Ahead.
If you start with n dollars,
and it's a fair game,
and you play until
you go broke, then
the probability that
you do go broke,
as opposed to playing
forever, is 1.
It's a certainty.
You'll go broke, even
though you expect it to take
an infinite amount of time.
All right, so let's prove that.
OK, the proof is
by contradiction.
Assume it's not true.
And that means that
you're assuming
that there exists
some number of dollars
that you can start with, and
some epsilon bigger than 0,
such that the probability
that you lose the n
dollars-- in which
case you're going home
broke-- let me write the
probability you go broke--
is at most 1 minus epsilon.
In other words, if the
theorem is not true,
there's some amount of money
you can start with such
that the chance you go broke
is less than 1-- less than 1
minus epsilon.
OK, now that means that for
all m, where you might possibly
stop but you're not
going to, the probability
you lose n before you win m
is at most 1 minus epsilon.
Because we're saying
the probability
you lose n no matter
what is at most that.
So it's certainly less
than 1 minus epsilon
that you lose n before
you win m dollars.
And we know what
that probability is.
This probability is
just m over n plus m.
We proved that earlier.
So that has to be less than
1 minus epsilon for all m.
And now I just multiply
through for all m.
That means that m is
less than or equal to 1
minus epsilon n plus m.
And then we'll solve that.
OK, so just multiply this out.
So for all m less than or
equal to n plus m minus epsilon
n minus epsilon m, and now
pull the m terms out here,
I get for all m,
epsilon m is less than
or equal to 1 minus epsilon n.
That means for all
m, m is smaller
than 1 minus epsilon
over epsilon times n.
And that can't be true.
It's not true the for all
m, this is less than that,
because these are fixed values.
That's a contradiction.
All right, so we
proved that if you
keep playing until
you're broke, you will go
broke with probability 1.
So even if you're playing a fair
game, quit while you're ahead.
Because if you don't,
you're going to go broke.
The swings will eventually
catch up with you.
So if we draw the graph here,
we'll see why that's true.
All right, if I have
time going this way,
and I start with n dollars,
my baseline is here.
The drift is 0.
I'm going to have swings.
I might have some
really big, high swings,
but it doesn't matter,
because eventually I'm
going to get a really bad swing,
and I'm going to go broke.
Now, if you ever
play a game where
you're likely to be winning each
time, and the drift goes up,
that's a good game
to play, obviously.
It just keeps getting better.
And that's a whole
math change there.
So that's it.
Remember, we have the ice
cream study session Monday.
So come to that if you'd like.
And definitely come to
the final on Tuesday.
And thanks for your
hard work, and being
such a great class this year.
[APPLAUSE]